whenever you watch a disney movie you
can be sure there will be an
easter egg or 10 hidden within it it's
no surprise then that raya and the last
dragon continues this proud tradition
and we're here to help you spot them
although pua the pig is a whole lot
cuter as far as animal sidekicks go
hey hey the rooster is the creature who
accompanies moana on her adventure
in her 2016 movie indeed the not so
bright bird winds up traveling with her
across the sea
after accidentally stowing away on her
boat he might be dimwitted but he still
manages to get into all sorts of
shenanigans
alan tudyk the actor who provided
heihei's voice also voices raya's pet
and steed tuk-tuk possibly as a nod to
tudyk's previous role
heihei shows up very briefly in talon's
busy central marketplace
tuktuk is raya's constant and adorable
companion and he's also her steed we
most frequently see him rolling
underneath raya like a living unicycle
this isn't just a neat idea though it's
a cultural reference
tuk-tuks are a type of vehicle commonly
seen in many southeast asian countries
also called an auto rickshaw
they are open-air have three wheels and
get their name from the sound they make
tuk-tuks originated in japan in the
1930s and went on to become popular
throughout southeast asia
raya's tuk-tuk might not be motorized
but he does make a slightly automotive
noise as he rolls along the roads of
kumandra
as raya walks through talon's busy
streets a number of shots reveal a dog
that looks somewhat like a
sholowitz queenly also called sholos the
type of dog portrayed in disney's coco
in fact this pooch might just be a
reference to miguel's beloved pet
dante though the dog isn't exactly a
visual match he could also be an easter
egg in reference to southeast asian
culture in keeping with the meticulous
design of the film the talon dog is most
likely to be a
southeast asian village dog village dogs
which are found throughout asia
are not quite domesticated and they are
not purebreds
they are genetically diverse and thought
to be descendants of the original
domesticated dogs of central asia from
15 000 years ago
in an interview with the hollywood
reporter lao visual anthropologist
steve arunsak discussed several of
raya's cultural details
including what inspired sisu's design
the legendary naga
in hinduism buddhism and jainism naga
are according to encyclopedia britannica
a member of a class of mythical
semi-divine beings half human and half
cobra
they have the ability to shapeshift and
can be good or bad though they're
usually good they also live near and
in bodies of water one big difference
between the naga and raya's dragons
though is that naga have no legs
design wise this would have made it very
hard to depict sisu holding the magical
dragon gem so the design of the dragons
was tweaked depictions of naga appear
throughout the lands of kumandra this
reflects real life
naga have been carved into doors adorned
canopy beds and guarded gates in the
form of enormous statues
basically they're revered both in the
film and an actual southeast asian
culture
raya's sword which belonged to her
father and what she uses after he has
turned to stone
has a dragon and gem for a hilt this
repeated motif is a depiction of sisu
the one being who binds the lands of
kumandra together even
as they drift apart additionally the
dragons who were turned to stone 500
years before the story begins dot the
landscape
when passing through a valley full of
the dormant creatures namari and her
entourage make sure to show them respect
but literal depictions of dragons aren't
the only way sisu and her magical
siblings are referenced in raya and the
last dragon
water symbols are everywhere in the film
one example is the raindrop motif on
raya's cape the dragon's powers over
water are a huge part of their magic
there's no life without water
of course and rain is a big part of that
relationship
after the dragon gem is shattered the
freshly empowered droon
attack kumandra with terrifying strength
it takes raya six long and arduous years
armed with a potent shard of the dragon
gem to search through
all of kumandra's rivers and eventually
find sisu
raya grasps the exhaustive nature of her
search as well as the audience does she
comments on how many tributaries the
main river of kumandra has when looking
at a map of her world
given that the main inspiration for that
key body of water is the real world
mekong river it's no wonder it took her
so much time
the mekong is about 2 700 miles long
this mighty river flows through and
between the southeast asian countries of
laos thailand myanmar cambodia and
vietnam
the mekong is also associated with the
legendary naga particularly the
mysterious phenomenon known as the naga
fireballs that makes a mekong inspired
river the perfect setting for raya's
search for sisu
much of the architecture of kumandra
resembles cambodia's iconic angkor wat
temple complex especially in fang
inspiration taken from the indonesian
ruma gadong style of house is also
evident though the term southeast asia
encompasses
several countries there are only five in
kumandra and so the filmmakers drew
inspiration from more than one when
developing each land's distinct
look consider the gorgeous chaotic
totally filled with thieves floating
market of talon
this unique environment draws
inspiration from two distinct southeast
asian settings the vietnamese water
markets of the mekong river and the
luminous night markets of thailand and
laos
such blended cultural details are also
apparent in the types of weapons each
land prefers the type of clothing
everyone wears and even people's jewelry
raya for example wears something very
reminiscent of the filipino salicott
this combination of various southeast
asian cultures allows for more of them
to be showcased in the film while firmly
establishing the fictional style of each
land
throughout most of raya and the last
dragon the audience sees raya as the
good princess
and namari as the bad one though of
course the film's climax reveals they
have far more in common than they think
one thing that is very different though
is their approach to fighting when we
first meet raya she's trying to get into
the temple in heart that houses the
dragon gem
in order to open a secret stone doorway
she pulls out two bamboo sticks and puts
them in holes in the stone to turn and
unlock it
those sticks are used in the filipino
martial arts form arnis which is also
known as kali and escrima
arnis is mainly defensive and involves
fighting with sticks
swords and daggers it is a combination
of various fighting forms developed over
thousands of years
raya also uses penchak silat which
combines the art of movement
self-defense physicality and
spirituality
furthermore chief benja's sword which
raya wields after her father has turned
to stone
is an indonesian chris which has a wavy
blade and is considered to be a
spiritual
object as well as a weapon in contrast
namara uses muay thai and krabi krabong
muay thai is somewhat similar to boxing
while krabi krabang
uses weapons both fighting styles
originated in thailand
as raya sisu and their friends travel
across kumandra
sisu frequently suggests giving gifts as
a way of getting their merry band into
the good graces of the people they're
visiting
the giving of gifts is tradition in all
of asia but there are different customs
in different countries
another important cultural norm is the
use of a hand gesture to greet others
this is given a twist in kumandra as the
characters make a gem shape with their
hands when meeting each other
as steve arunsak told the hollywood
reporter that's a creative take on the
common greetings you'll see in the
entire
southeast asian region where you have
clasped hands it's called a nap in lao
and a y in thai but it's the same theme
of bringing your hands together
in kumandra the height of the gesture
indicates the amount of respect given
sisu receives the highest greetings of
all even from noi and her mischievous
pack of angkies
after raya and sisu meet 12 year old
boone he winds up going with them on
their quest for the remaining pieces of
the dragon gem
this allows the party to travel aboard
his boat or as he calls it his
shrimp emporium boone ferries them from
land to land along kumandra's river but
he doesn't do it for free
raya has to offer him some of her jade
as payment as they travel things become
increasingly perilous for the gang
fairy men frequently function as symbols
in literature and myth consider
charon a figure from greek mythology who
ferries the dead across the river styx
to hades
a dangerous journey on a good day the
dead need to give karen one coin as fair
for safe passage much like raya has to
bribe boone with jade
likewise at the climax of the film all
the characters except
nomari wind up turned to stone a form of
death that is undone once namari is able
to put the dragon gem back together and
defeat the droon
the gem is used as a form of payment
albeit one that brings the dead back
over the border to the land of the
living
savvy disney fans know that the studio
loves hiding mickeys all over the place
there are in fact
multiple books and websites dedicated to
finding every hidden mickey possible a
hidden mickey isn't an actual drawing of
mickey mouse placed somewhere as in a
where's waldo puzzle however it's a
simple representation of mickey's head
one larger circle with two smaller
circles on it in a recent interview with
malaysian website says directors don
hall and carlos lopez
estrada stated that there are hidden
mickeys in the land of talon including
tiny little ones
if we're correct about one of those tiny
little ones then the three dotted
patterns on talon chief
dank hughes hat certainly count other
possible hidden mickeys can be seen to
the right of the kitchen
raya and her father enter early in the
film and on the larger of raya's leather
armbands
it's not a huge secret that disney
sometimes recycles animation in its film
but sometimes a scene is less recycled
than it is deliberately
echoing another disney property in this
case the shipwreck scene in raya and the
last dragon echoes the one in frozen two
in frozen two anna and elsa find a
shipwreck which turns out to be the ship
on which their parents perished
and what might be a rye nod to that
scene when raya and tuktuk come to the
end of their search for sisu they find a
wrecked ship
raya comments six years of searching and
we end up at a literal shipwreck is the
film making fun of anna and elsa's sad
discovery
probably not but pointing out such a
similar scene even though it has a
different outcome
is no doubt a wink to the easter egg
savvy disney fan
the hollywood reporter quoted director
don hall as saying that some of rya's
swagger is pulled from guardians of the
galaxy star-lord
who star-lord man legendary outlaw
that's definitely not the only movie
raya references when tongue decides to
throw in his lot with raya and sisu he
says
i wish to join this fellowship of butt
hickory
we're counting this as a shout out to
another fantasy epic the lord of the
rings the fellowship of the ring
raya even wears her childhood hair ring
on a necklace after all just like frodo
does with the one ring
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one